[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are kicking
off september
oh that's good have we done that before
sex timber
man we're having uh an incredible
conversation with a qualified
professional who knows all about sex
more than just a couple of
boys have been having sex with the same
ladies for a long for a long time and
before you give emily's bio just want to
say hey this podcast and this iteration
of sex timber 2022
may not be for you um so use your own
discretion if you want to keep listening
the disclaimer is say why the reason why
is because we talk about we talk very
specifically and explicitly about
sex
okay
so we're not holding anything back we're
not beating around the bush
ma'am we're already there um
so
proceed
in
informed you know make an informed
decision if you want to be a part of
this but i gotta tell you
um
if you're up for it
this could be
this could be really encouraging it
could be really enlightening it could be
really educational it could be really
exciting
and we we're
we're breaking down the stigmas
we can talk about sex
yeah and we don't have to not just in
september but that is we don't have to
apologize for it right so
give the bio and then let's get into it
with emily emily morse is a doctor of
human sexuality and a sex therapist
she's recognized as one of today's most
insightful sex educators challenging
cultural taboos misinformation and
awkward sex talks love it to create a
future where people can deeply connect
and shamelessly embrace pleasure love it
she's the host of sex with emily a
podcast that's been going on for a long
time uh
2005. and it's what she's doing it might
be the preeminent sex podcast i'm going
to say that it is the preeminent sex
podcast she's inspired millions of
people to normalize sex and pleasure by
creating a safe space where people can
explore
and that's exactly what we did with her
in this episode we explored many topics
yeah right right off right off the bat
here it is good mythical evening has
been rescheduled you can still watch it
you can rent it on video on demand that
will be available from september 12th
through september 18th you can rent it
up to 9 p.m pacific that's midnight
eastern and then watch that rental so
get in on the action goodmythical
evening.com it's really happening this
time yeah
emily thanks for being here
thanks for having me
now we we talk about sex one month out
of the year you talk about sex all the
time
yeah well speak for yourself man
you talk about okay well what i mean off
the show we'll talk about it and
publicly every once in a while you just
go out in public and talk about sex on
the street corners yeah
yeah okay
so okay yes
well okay
i'm not going to assume that you know
anything about our background but i'm
just going to so one of the reasons that
we waited to talk about
sex publicly
is our
very we come from a very conservative
evangelical christian background that we
have since uh exited that world okay and
of course so there was a lot of like hey
if we're gonna talk about sex
you gotta talk about it in the right
context etc and so it took us a while to
get to a place where he's like hey let's
just rip the band-aid off and just tell
people that this is actually how we
think
uh and it's been incredibly freeing
uh you know to be able to discuss this
stuff but we haven't ever really
discussed it with a professional before
okay we're just going off our experience
it's time and all our experiences with
one woman each
oh with your with your wife's with your
partners that's right
well especially well that's thanks for
that background because growing up in an
environment like
let me just say this
most people
on the planet
are not comfortable talking about sex
it makes them uncomfortable obviously
they're not comfortable it's um there's
a lot of judgment there's a lot of fear
especially who grew up in very religious
backgrounds i think a lot of my
listeners are people who are they're
still in that space or have moved beyond
that space or left that space but it's
still like how do you start talking
about something that was so demonized
your entire life and now we're going to
talk about it so it's mixed messages and
then no matter where you grew up society
doesn't actually welcome it with open
arms there's so much misinformation
about sex so it's just i'm just glad
that we've all arrived here today
yeah but i get why it's not easy we want
to we we're countering that now we're
just being totally open and saying hey i
think there's a lot of health and just
putting it out there and that's why i
just want to start by jumping into
orgasms okay well can we can we talk
about arg
all types of orgasms i want to have
every type of orgasm
that can be had and that's that's what i
wanted i'm sorry that's what i want to
get out of it but you know what there's
no there's no shame in asking that
question but it's just the way you
framed it when you said i want to jump
into orgasms that was how you
you could have said let's talk about
orgasms
you know
yeah
is there a jumping orgasm can i can
i do think one of those little
trampolines like the little exercise
trampolines if you if you jump on one of
those long enough and hard enough i do
believe you can have an orgasm on one
really
i mean you could probably have an orgasm
anywhere if you really wanted to but um
sure that would be an interesting place
but i don't think we should jump here's
the problem with orgasms we think we
should just be able to snap our hands
and jump right into orgasms but it takes
a little bit of warm-up something called
foreplay something called understanding
the orgasm so
i know i know that
for the most part i mean i'm just saying
when it comes to
i mean i'm not going to have an orgasm
right here yeah i'm just going to have a
conversation about it right exactly cool
because that's a whole different show
i don't know that's not even my show
[Music]
i want to learn about new orgasms and
then i want to i want to so that i can
experience it what do you mean well
what do you know what do you think he
means by new orgasms
unclear right because i here's the thing
i always want to meet people where
they're at
and i'm not sure how much what you know
about orgasms what's new to you might
not be new to someone else
well
i've had a
i've had an orgasm uh
with my
with my penis
that's great
that is a penile orgasm
yeah that's an orgasm that's a real
orgasm
and i love those as well i'm a real i'm
a big fan of those
rights they're a good time
um
i don't know what other types there are
that i could have uh
you yeah so why do we get into that
especially because you guys are in male
bodies because you have penises i can't
say all the things here right like
really like that's a typical term you
have a penis so people of penises um
they can also have something called a
prostate orgasm
because uh men have a prostate and so
that's through your anus there's this
wonderful little walnut shaped
um
but clumps of nerve endings um there
that you could find about two inches
inside with a finger or a toy
two inches inside
but yeah there's a wall two inches
there's a walnut yes
kind of like a walnut you don't even
have to eat walnuts i get it i've heard
about this this is a this is a good one
to start with because i've i've i've
never had one of these
but i did have a friend one time who
told me that if i
that i should he he described it and i
was like oh my god i gotta i gotta have
one of these are you talking about the
milking the milking of the prostate is
that what you're talking about i don't
know what i'm talking about
what is it
what is it like what do you do to the
walnut
okay you said two inches
it's about it yeah you should have two
you gotta find it kind of find it
yourself um but or someone could find it
for you but it's sort of like you could
put a finger inside and it takes a
little bit of practice but it's like a
come hither motion
towards your belly button and it's
similar to how to find a g-spot on a
female partner in the sense of it's that
same motion like towards the belly
button i don't know why my hands are
like this i am too i'm showing you put
them away
um and so yeah that how you find it and
so what happens is it's sort of
responsible for um
yeah you can it can help the amazing
thing about it and the reason why you
don't know about it is because
there is a lot of people who believe
that if they ever explored that area
the prostate and one could feel amazing
that it would somehow define their
sexuality
like maybe it'll make me gay maybe it'll
people think things and and i don't
think that that that the um that the gay
community particularly has
has a um you know a lot down on the
prostate market it just means that they
like kind of discovered it in other ways
that we feel shame about but i'm telling
you a sex doesn't make you gay if you
were into it which i hope that you might
be after today that's amazing and there
has to be some exploring and some you
know
hunting around but once you find it it
can feel incredible and it's sort of
stimulating this different part so it's
different than a uh your regular orgasm
it's different than orgasmic your penis
because you're stimulating the prostate
which is like seminal fluid in it and
when you kind of it feels different but
it can feel incredible so for the
majority of penis owners as i call them
on my show
um they say that it's a very intense
feeling that they feel throughout their
whole body
and it's a little bit more
you know intense
and yeah not more more intense than uh
yes then i was going to say a normal
orgasm but i don't want to say that
because that's okay then a wiener orgasm
i didn't know no more intense i didn't
know i was gonna have to go here so
early in this conversation um
if you're about to tell me that you've
had one of these and you haven't told me
about it i'm gonna be pretty i don't
tell you everything man but this is i
mean if this is like an earth-shattering
orgasm and you're like keeping it to
yourself
i i had to talk to another friend who
told me about it uh
i think i know who you're talking about
so okay well you tell me this so i
what i'll say is that i don't
necessarily think that i
you know
my wife and i have figured out like the
what you might call the milking of the
the the prostate but
isn't there a similar thing
is that a thing oh man did he just make
that up i i i wasn't looking at the
prostate is stimulating the prostate i'm
glad that i did not think about this
ahead of time because milk come out of
it it's seminal fluid dude
comes out of comes out of where you okay
do you know you know what it uses the
fluid in semen but it's like the size of
the shape of the walnut but there's also
the seminal fluid that comes out of it
like so when you so you ejaculate hold
on let me yeah i know a little bit about
this we used to call it pre when we were
growing up right you remember that like
especially when you were like a teenager
and you were hanging out with a hot girl
and spending time with her and then all
of a sudden spending time you get home
and and for me i honestly didn't even
have to like she it what nothing had to
happen sometimes it was just like
something could happen and just the
thought of something could happen you
get home and you look in your drawers
and you're like
uh there's
i was read there was some stuff
happening where i was getting ready for
this right that's seminal fluid yeah
right yeah you guys you've experienced
yes right
so yes i love that by the way so here
here's what i will tell you and i'm
trying i'm just again i i thought we
would warm up to this but you're the one
who decided to jump into it we jump into
orgasms
this is not sex this is conversation
about sex we've got to jump into it uh
so
i have uh experimented with uh
[Music]
a butt plug nice
[Laughter]
uh yeah nervous nervous laughs
is this is this surprising to you it's
offensive to me why is it offensive to
you because you didn't you didn't share
it with me i'm not gonna share my butt
plug with you man like that's unsanitary
you're not even really supposed to share
it with your partner unless you like
boil it ahead of time
a boiling bl butt plug that sounds
like torture um no you wait for it to
cool before you insert it uh i meant
share the experience i had not the
experience
like
loop me in like an e like an email an
email
term is lube you in actually because
lube is very important now just like
just like a dm just anything that's like
a text maybe uh
emily asked me about button what i'll
say is that this this you know this
intrigued me this intrigued me a while
ago i think the first time i
um
uh experimented with one i mean it's i
think it was probably 15 years ago i was
i was still very much like a
evangelical
christian you know conservative but my
view towards sex and in the way that my
wife and i think about sex has always
been very open and and kind of
adventurous so
um
but but it was kind of like i don't like
i don't know i kind of makes me feel
like i'm i'm having about to take a sh
and like you you know like you i didn't
know how to really embrace it so it
hasn't been something that has happened
but you purchased one and you yeah yeah
and you did you you you plugged your
your your butt yeah with a very small
one
yeah and then
you didn't come to work that way did you
no but i know from listening to emily's
podcast
that there are people who will go to
work and wear a butt plug all day right
yeah yeah
some people you learned that from yeah
people probably called in and asked how
long is too long to wear about plug i
mean it's not a common question but
you know
there's some sanitary issues i wouldn't
wear it all day long you know just like
anything you probably gotta change it
after a while maybe a few hours as max
but some people really love the
sensation of having something and this
goes for all genders um it can feel
really hot to have something inside of
you all day because there's all these
nerve endings i think we need to break
down why it feels good too
okay yeah so many nerves are you still
okay are you recovered from the fact
that rhett didn't share this with you
i'll be good to me yeah yeah yeah i mean
just to use an analogy i feel like we
jumped right into this sex timber
conversation and i was thinking that i
was personally like proverbially going
to be lubed up a little bit before i put
the butt plug in so to speak and i just
feel like you kind of forced me into it
to be to be frank with you sorry uh and
there wasn't consensus
i just said sorry i'm just ass like
that's literally where i left that
statement i don't know why i meant to
say asking the penetrating questions
well what i will say which i think is
what you're getting at here emily is
that there is a
uh
there's a point in which you're like i
understand the the additional sensation
that this offers the additional
seminal fluid that this this offers the
situation it hasn't been the kind of
thing that like i i know just from
you know
reading that there are some people who
are like hey once i went back once i
went to that i never went back and i
always have one in every time i have sex
that's not my experience but i
definitely think it's worth
experimenting with and there might be
some benefits so emily i can i can send
you a butt plug
we can talk after this hold on here you
go do you have like do you have like a
yeah you should mercy you have a
proprietary butt plug yeah i know but i
get so many sent to me prostate toys to
test oh we need people to test them all
the time but you don't have to report
back just as a gift
my gift to you
it seems like i'm the one who needs it
it does the butt plug
stimulate the prostate
and so it gives you a prostate orgasm i
always want my assistant to write
because we actually are recording my
house now she can almost like go run and
grab a butt plug in a prostate toy
to show you because we're on video like
let's like you know we're there they're
actually jenna jenna jenna zara says
jenna can you run and grab brett's butt
plug do you know about this yeah i know
exactly where it is
that is the first we gave jenna a mic
that is the first thing she ever said
that she knew
they they gave me a mic for a vulva a
person with a vulva's point of view on
this end good i'm so glad you're here
i'm so glad you're here truly truly um
so but anyway where are we so so yes a
bug plug is great and that can be used
all genders but plug can put it inside
and it feels great um because there's so
many nerve endings right inside like a
blood plug might only go in like an inch
or two which i know that said that's
where the prostate is but it's a little
bit harder to find with a butt plug a
butt plug will not necessarily stimulate
the entire prostate however a prostate
toy which is shaped like the internal
part of a prostate that like your
prostate's a little bit longer it has
some vibrations that go inside it it can
also vibrate oh there we go
this might be your
oh i don't know if any of these are
prostate thoughts oh they're
it might be hard to find the tantrum
that is so funny what's the line they're
like black okay let me find out and they
i don't know what the point picture but
this is okay these are all the butt
plugs i just happen to have in my uh
in my storage but is that just a big box
or is that a big butt plug or does it ha
does that have a remote control yes you
guys so much has happened in these years
i'm telling you rhett since you use your
last butt plug you guys i can send
whatever you're interested to they also
don't come in pink if you want like a
black one or a blue one but
this is one by v vibe but they it has a
remote control there's other ones that
you could use with your phone
where you individually like you could
send your partner you can make calls
with the butt plug i'm not gonna listen
i'm not talking i am not talking to my
mom through a butt plug if my if my mom
if my mom calls me up while i've got
that thing in me i am not answering okay
no i i recommend that's that's a strong
no but but you can have your partner
control it from the phone
what happens what happens with it just
vibrates
so some of these vibrate some place some
some don't um but but you put them
inside and it's just sort of like this
one is a great this is by revive it's
like it's called the ditto
and if this one does vibrate it goes
inside
and this part also here goes inside but
this stimulates the perineum which is
like the taint
the tank like it takes yes oh you know
the changes tincture ass it takes your
balls is whatever they say this part is
really sensitive to men too like right
uh before the yeah the tape the area
right there so if this goes inside of
you this butt plug then right here this
also vibrates and you can just kind of
push it up against it's like everything
that you put in your butt should have a
flared edge it should flare so you don't
get it doesn't get lost so you can so
you don't have to go to the er and be
one of those stories you don't want to
be on the show sex takes you did sex
unless you do want to be on that channel
do any of these do do any of these uh
products because i think where we might
be able to really get link involved in
this
do any of these remote control butt
plugs
also double as like a bluetooth speaker
because i feel like if he could pump uh
hip hop to his ass
this is the kind of thing that he would
love that might be your entry point
quest well the entry point is the anus
uh i i understand that
there is another company that makes one
that you can set to your your playlist
and it will vibrate along with your
playlist yes oh yes this okay thank you
good job so tell us tell me how to use
this thing let's just but yeah exactly
i'm getting really over
head here and all the things so what you
do is
you so this is just a program okay so
this one is the prostate toy can you see
this so it's orgasm 20 anniversary
there's so much guys i'm obsessed with
this um brand because aneros is like
knows all about it so this one looks a
little bit more like your prostate right
like this one fits in a little bit more
snug but i recommend for any kind of
anal play starting with something a
little smaller like a butt plug okay
okay how you start is the first thing i
would recommend if you haven't ever even
ventured into that area then maybe when
you're having your alone time like if
it's your masturbating or with your
partner your wife
to first just explore
anal play like what does it actually
feel like even to have a finger outside
of my anus because there's a lot of like
muscles that feel really great like the
sphincter muscles are very sensitive in
that area like you don't want to go from
zero to eight oh that's all i'm saying
like
yeah let's build up
that's gonna be the that's gonna be the
name of this episode
[Laughter]
that's exactly what we did yes
so you want to start out with fingers
maybe your own fingers are your
partner's fingers you want to always
make sure that your hands are clean your
fingernails are trimmed you are your
partners or probably everyone's and you
want to use a lot of lube
because the anus is not self-lubricating
so you want to make sure you use lube
and you explore and you think like what
and you just kind of maybe use a finger
what does that feel like to even have
something inside of me i wouldn't go
from like zero to like a bigger toy at
first
so you try that out and you go very slow
and you communicate well with your
partner and you're like oh that actually
does feel good or might feel good and
then you can graduate to a butt plug
again you put that in slowly there's a
ceremony when you when you graduate to
the butt plug there is a ceremony
there's a tassel and everything
just so you know i can send you my i can
send you my gown okay
will your mom be at my ceremony yeah
yeah my dad will be filming it with his
little video camera too because he films
all my graduations
this will be one he's never been like
the likes he's never seen is there a
quick question for you i want to know is
there any other prep because once i
start to talk about the good stuff i
don't want to have to go back and talk
about the um
make sure that you're about
empty
make sure that you don't need to uh go
number two
well here's the thing
hygiene so let's just talk about all the
worries that people have and that's one
of them like first is like is it going
to make me like people will think i'm
gay if i'm not gay um or that's both
matters yeah we're over that you're
beyond that thank god okay good okay the
other thing is
we know what makes you gay and it's
who you are
yeah it's who you are who you sleep with
perhaps
not a toy so after you feel good about
that the hygiene part is about just
cleaning out your bowel like cleaning i
mean you know when you've gone to the
bathroom and you haven't so typically
sometimes
sometimes as i get older it's harder to
figure out let's not
i want to i want to hear this part but i
don't want to dwell on it okay go ahead
we're going to do something this is a
barrier
okay so we're gonna talk about it so you
know you know like when you've gone or
you haven't like if it's been 12 hours
and you you've gone like let's say you
know this is my natural bowel cycle okay
that's so that you're pretty much fine
if it's like oh i had a really big meal
last night i had lots of beans rice
whatever i haven't gone yet not the best
day just to try them
right
but maybe
is it okay so is there any more
is there another level of clean
like
i i i'm a fan of cleaning all types of
things matter of fact but my problem is
i clean things too much well this is
okay again i happen to listen to the the
right episode and it's first so it's
very fresh in my memory but i love this
uh the doctor that you were talking to
the first half of your the anal episode
he has his own
essentially like he has his own anal
douche what's it called future yeah
future method dr evan goldstein yep
future back
i have a um
uh i can't even i have a bidet
well that'll take care of some of it
some of it
let's see here's the thing is that okay
so i actually talked about i think i
talked about this on the podcast is that
um
maybe i didn't well but we're already
here so
every once in a while i told you because
you do the same thing there's been a
couple of times when you're about to
travel i know when i'm about to travel
yeah and i'm like i'm gonna be on a
plane today i'm gonna i've got to get
there's a connection i don't like on a
plane or really at an airport oh yeah
yeah yeah so i'm a big fan of like do a
little enema enemy but they're traveling
i i have to travel with an enema because
i get all i get all clogged up
i'm totally good with it
i love it but see i'm pulling you back
from that because what i learned on
emily's podcast from the from the doctor
that what's his name dr evan goldstein
evan goldstein if you're just using like
water or or it's like a traditional
enema solution you're actually like
taking things out of the lining that's
like a protective lining so he's got
some like ph balance special blend okay
some guy's trying to sell me something
yeah but it is but let me tell you this
so you don't need to you could go to the
grocery store you go to the store
wherever you buy your items and you can
buy the enema that comes with the
vinegar pour out all that vinegar don't
use that and then just use the hot water
and do that and then flush it through
your system one or two times so you feel
everything's out
okay okay i i'm good there that's easy
right just do that and then you have
confidence
yeah that it's not a question so you've
done a little anal play is what i hear i
mean if you want to if you if you if you
want to call it's always felt like an
emergency i know but i'm saying that
like
i would say that you are
and i'm not speaking for all men or all
men who grew up in our environment with
our background but
we we are all uncomfortable with the
idea of like that right and so
but the dookie shoe the fact that the
fact that you are doing an enema or a
pre-travel enema and then talking about
it on the internet you're way ahead of
the
game you know you're ready to you're
ready to go on to middle school and then
the graduation into the butt plug zone
but
i'm gonna i'm gonna lap you buddy
this is not a competition
the question i have for you emily is um
how do how do you address couples
or people in general
who are like man
like we aren't even having sex on a
regular basis we're not even talking
about sex or like we do it the same way
every single time so like we are
seven layers removed from
butt plug graduation mode
right
what do you what do you think is the key
to because i think that the thing that's
that that we find is that
you know when you just talk about this
stuff and you start exploring it
together as a couple
there's just there's a world of fun that
you're just leaving on the table if you
are just like uh this makes me feel
uncomfortable and i'm not trying to
shame anybody who's not you know who may
not be his cousin you don't have to be
comfortable with all this stuff that
doesn't make you normal or abnormal or
whatever but if you kind of are
interested and you want to do this but
the idea of
broaching this topic with your partner
is something that makes your
sphincter completely shrivel up uh
how do you address those people
such a good question because mo i would
say again
i love this question because this is the
challenge most couples
have a hard time talking about sex and
most couples in long-term relationships
have gotten or have gotten or will get
to the point where sex has become kind
of
mundane
wrote a little bit stale
and maybe they even stopped having sex
and they literally don't know what to do
how to talk about it or where to start
again to kind of bring back that spark
and if you haven't talked about sex and
nothing's been happening well again i
probably wouldn't go from
not talking about sex to anal like i
would probably start in another area
yeah and so i would recommend is
um is really just i have these three t's
of communication
and they've helped many many people and
it's timing
tone and turf
because what i found is that we don't
know how to bring this topic up like
maybe you want more sex than your
partner or maybe you both realize it
hasn't been happening yet you really
don't know how to talk about it and you
keep hoping it's going to get better or
one day your partner's going to come
home and be like i'm ready and
and it's just or that just that it's
just died and the first thing i want to
do is normalize that for every couple
that is in a long-term relationship
i hate saying every because it's like no
we haven't fight but the majority 99 of
a couple is gonna get the point where
they get into a sexual run
um and that's because we don't talk
about sex
we are not comfortable with it and we
assume that when there's a problem with
our sex life it probably means either
like we shouldn't be together anymore
it's something i did wrong i'm no longer
attractive my partner doesn't find me
attractive and we create all these
stories on our head and since we don't
have a lot of great examples
of people talking about sex we just
decided to say nothing so with timing
tone and turf which is a great way to
have it you've never like i'm going to
assume for the majority of the listening
it's gotten stale or for you guys maybe
i know you didn't say that but you're
not really sure how to broach it
and so when you the timing is when you
are just
hanging out you're not hult i like to
say hungry angry lonely or tired so make
sure none of those things are happening
but you're in a good place i'm always
hungry though i know well one of them at
least you're not so hungry that you're
going to be cranky
and then so that's the that's the um
that's the timing like it's not going to
be after the last time you got
frustrated that the sex didn't happen
and then you're like why didn't it
happen again
no it's that time and then your tone is
compassionate and it's curious
and it's like hey i realized that we
haven't talked about our sex life in a
long time
and i realized that we probably both
want to be great lovers to each other
so
maybe we can start to figure out ways to
talk about it and i'd let you know that
i'd love to find ways to so we can both
get our needs met
be wonderful lovers to each other have
more satisfaction
and the conversation just goes from
there and then the tone the turf is
outside the bedroom many couples think
that the conversation should have in the
happen in the bedroom because if you
were talking about like a recipe it
would happen in the kitchen but the
bedroom i believe
deeply believe it should be for sleeping
and for sex so to have the conversations
when you're like on a road trip you're
hanging out together you're just in a
good mellow space so you're on my side
you believe no talking in the bedroom
yeah
yeah not about these things you can
dirty talk in the bedroom
uh so and at what point do you reveal
that you've had a butt plug in the whole
time
well if it has a tail off if it has if
it has a tail on it oh which i haven't
done that you can do that you can get
them with tails
like a
oh
yeah i haven't done that yet but i feel
like you know
after this conversation if you gank on
it does it make raccoons you don't want
to yank on it
just a little a light tug at most okay
okay
all right
that that question was very question was
very helpful but honestly it just wasn't
juicy enough for me what's another
orgasm that i can have oh we're back to
orgasms okay another one that you can
have or that your partner can have yeah
let's focus on what our partners are
okay let's talk about the partner
okay
so what kind of orgasms do we know about
with our partner so you've got the
you've got the
clitoral orgasm and then you've got the
vaginal orgasm and those are different
even though the clitoris can extend all
the way inside
depending on the the person's anatomy
right it goes further than others all
right so i
i'm familiar with these concepts good i
love this we're so good
so there is a clinical orgasm which we
all know the clitoris we might not know
is 8 000 nerve endings i'm actually
going to show you another prop here
we've got a you got a clitoris puppet
yes please
i wonder what voice she's going to use
for it
oh that's a good point
hello this is your vulva
no i think i think you need to go again
like go like
oscar the girl
oh my god
what does he do oh he's asleep cookie if
that's a cookie monster i don't know if
i can break into author i don't think i
can break it out of the garage but you
guys can narrate the vulva no you do it
don't let no
i'm the left vulva
[Laughter]
are you the right one
with you i'm sorry
look up here in between us
look at that man in the boat
[Laughter]
yeah that's good good oh there's only
one job
there's only one volvo but you could be
the labias there's two labias oh yeah
right
yeah you're talking about right and left
volvo's on the left labia so let me just
say this the vulva
is referring to the external part of the
vagina
which a lot of people interchange the
vagina listen i am guilty of this
what i said last year and i've tried to
take responsibility for this
but okay so we talked a little bit about
our my spiritual background but i said
that i thought that the
best exist the best um
evidence for the existence of god is the
vagina right it's my favorite thing in
the in the world and then everyone went
on to tell me that what you're really
talking about is the vulva
yeah but it just it just sounds when you
say it in the context of like a
colloquial like philosophical thing it
feels like i know i'm technically wrong
but when you say vulva it kind of sounds
like in that context you're trying to
like prove that you know all the term
knowledge so you're but but
just be wrong about it just be wrong
dude i said i'm technically just be
totally i'm spiritually right no just be
totally wrong
okay the best existence the best
evidence for the existence of god is the
vulva
there i said it
okay
great i love it
i'm with you great good
you're gonna tell me that the clitoris
has more
nerve endings than the than the head of
the penis
i've heard that yes yes in fact the
clitoris has 8 000 nerve writings and
the penis circumcised penis has 4
thousand
oh man from an evolutionary standpoint
it's weird that it's
separated from
the uh the insertion point you know it's
like because it seems like
again just
evolutionarily speaking i you know if
you're thinking about procreation that
the most
the the insertion of the penis into the
vagina should
like why aren't the nerve endings down
there
i wonder
this is such a good question i am so
glad you brought it up it's because
we've been told and you guys might be
familiar to this from your upbringing
that sex is all about procreation
penis goes into vagina
we are procreating
sex happens baby's born and that's the
only time we should be having sex that
is the marketing machine behind sex that
it's procreation but what we've come to
find out is that the truth is the
majority of people with vulvas will not
have an orgasm with penetration for
exactly the reasons you're talking about
because when there is a penis going in
here it is nowhere even scraping or
saying hello
to the clitoris so the majority of women
and i would say only
25 of women have an orgasm with a penis
in their vagina so procreation i mean so
penetration
was all about procreation
and otherwise you were ashamed if you
would any other kind of sex in many
places in the world well and and also in
in media like
everything we grew up watching it was
just oh okay so when you're having sex
with a woman
like
you're thrust you're thrusting and then
eventually she has an orgasm from this
act and oh and and and you probably have
it exactly the same time if you're
really good at it you know and so that
was the that was the the thought that we
all brought into
yeah fake fake news fake proper it's
fake sexual propaganda was all about
that so so what i'm saying is but here's
what i want to tell you the good news is
so let's just say like these are the
labias this is the clitoral hood this is
the this is the clitoris but just so you
know when i think you mentioned this
earlier
is that it has 8 000 you did mention
that but it's not just this little bulb
do you know that the clitoris has legs
that extend deep inside so here's the
actual clitoris and it goes behind this
structure
exactly it's a wishbone
and this part
right here is the clitoris but
everything else is internal so those 8
000 nerve endings are right behind the
labia see what i mean
and so when you are stimulating it here
that's great but it's also stimulating
internally all these areas that feel
good with the legs of the clitoris this
is the clitoral legs yeah i think that
answers if i go like purely scientific
and
evolutionary theory here the
developmentally
the um the clitoris is
is comparable to the
to the to the head of the penis but then
as a as a human develops it either turns
into a penis or it turns into uh based
on clitoris and everything based on
hormones in the in the process
and i do think that what so maybe from
an evolutionary standpoint that like the
clitoris has gone down there more than i
realized more than you realize yeah the
penis and the clitoris are analogous
truly and i don't want to i want to keep
giving you merch ideas but i just had
another one i think you need to start
selling the clitoral hoodie
oh uh
i mean i love that that just feels like
it's gonna sell itself i mean it doesn't
have to i mean it's just a hoodie
with maybe like maybe there's a cool
sort of abstract clitoris design on the
back or the front so you don't really
know but you just on your website is the
clitoral hoodie i also think
that
dr emily could sell a travel pillow that
is shaped like a clitoris like this is
the this is the entire clitoris
and then you wrap it around your neck
and it's a great conversation you're
always educating and then you're you're
sleeping you're yeah what a what better
way to sleep than being
wrapped in a clitoris
swaddled swaddled with your clitoris
right
yeah so i love it what are we what are
we
what do i what can i do that i haven't
been doing well but before you get there
because i the you didn't like that
question no no because i don't i don't
want to leave this subject yet because
first of all i'm going to have to i mean
my wife is fine with me talking about a
lot of stuff i'll obviously have to ask
her i'm going to go ahead and just
disclose some things and then i'll ask
her before we release this episode if
this was okay perfect but so
um
i think she is typical of a lot of women
and that the you know
i would say every orgasm has been a
clitoral orgasm but there has been over
the past 20 years there has been the
quest for the vaginal orgasm right which
is like oh i think it's about to happen
oh is it oh is it is it is it going to
happen
and so what do you think about that
quest is that something that is it is it
something that you should just abandon
is it something no
okay no don't ever abandon the
exploration of your bodies and there's a
lot of different
theories around the internal orgasm aka
the g-spot in fact i sort of don't even
think it's a spot i think it's more like
an area
and i'd also think that it's a lot of is
connected to the the clitoral
the clitoral legs so when you go inside
of here like
well first let me tell you this it's
it's very the easiest way or the one of
the first steps to actually having an
internal orgasm or a g-spot orgasm is
making sure that you have a clitoral
orgasm first that you're already
stimulated you're already turned on
because the blood becomes more engorged
you're you get swollen you get turned on
and then you're more likely to be able
to find the g-spot which much like the
prostate is about an inch and a half
inside using your fingers in a coma
heather motion
trying to find this little rough area
which could be like the g area so that's
that's the spot
and it helps again to be aroused and
then you just kind of use that with the
finger and just kind of penetrate to
kind of like feel around and
apply pressure and see where that goes
it could be a blended orgasm too when
she already has a
clitoral orgasm so it's just easier to
have like a blended one so it feels like
all of them and again for some people
and i believe there's two i love a good
smoothie
a blended smoothie a blended orgasm
smoothie
why not they sell that at air one i
think or they should be yeah
um it's way too expensive though and you
gotta give them enough
um but but yeah so no i i think that
with toys and with fingers and we're
talking about it i think that
many many women can find this elusive
g-spot but
orgasm but it's not gonna happen through
a penis for many like if it hasn't
happened yet after 20 years
this has nothing to do with your penis
it has everything to do with them
anatomy if you put a hundred women in a
room and you looked at all of them
touching themselves let's say they were
all like doing the thing that makes them
feel good they'd all be doing something
different because our vaginas our vocals
are like snowflakes and they're all
different so every single woman needs
something else
so it's a little that's
cold gotta warm it up
like a snowflake well in a room full of
dudes you'd see him doing different
stuff we knew a guy in high school that
did a two-hand thing like this he would
make this
he did that kind of thing
yeah he did remember well we didn't we
didn't witness it but he did choose to
talk no but he just told i guess one of
those conversations where everybody was
disclosing and they were talking about
the double hand diamond yeah well link
admitted that he uses his left hand uh
which is just another piece of evidence
that he's left-handed he also holds a
microphone with his left hand sorry if
you didn't want me to share that we
could edit it out
and then another friend talked about the
double the double thing so i mean guys
do it in all kinds of different ways as
well guys do all different ways too
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right and so um right we all
do differently but have fun and i also
recommend couples do this together like
a mutual masturbation
sesh is a super hot thing for couples to
do to be like i am going to look at what
i do i want to turn myself on you're
going to train you're going to do your
thing and then i'm going to like there's
two reasons why i love this because
you're going to see what turns your
partner on and that's really hot to see
them touch themselves but you're also
going to learn like what are they
actually doing how do they touch
themselves if they masturbate which i
hope they do yeah and then you just
learn you learn and you slow down it's a
process but if it hasn't happened all
these years and there's nothing wrong
with you either because again the
majority of women are not and it has to
do with their anatomy it has to do with
biologically speaking how closely their
vaginal opening is to their clitoris
and for those women they're more likely
to have more internal
orgasms but for the other ones they
gotta experiment with there's some great
toys
fingers taking the pressure off
experimenting and having a clitoral
orgasm first
that's my best
recommendations for that orgasm
so
i'm trying to think what else
what else is there down there that can
be splendid
squirting let's talk about that okay
what what what
what's my question here um is it p and
doesn't it
thank you thank you that's the top
question
okay well first of all squirting i did a
show on squirting if i didn't want to
check it out sex with emily can you
imagine this it's like the most popular
show i've done in 20 years
but i had a squirty i mean people just
love talking about squirting but what it
is is
it is
liquids for its period parallel urethral
fluids
there are traces of urine they have done
studies of women who completely empty
their bladders and then they have an
orgasm and then yes there's still urine
in it
um
my answer to that is so what
who cares does it feel good throw a
sheet down but there was a lot of debate
like is it pee is it whatever so i don't
know like if we want to spend time there
great
but i don't think it matters but what i
can say is that for many women they can
squirt or female ejaculate by
stimulating the female prostate which we
also have one as well where is that
the the female prostate is sort of
inside the vaginal i think you guys
should just listen to this show we did
with deborah sundell who like in the 70s
started like
teaching women to squirt but the
prostate is like once you get aroused
and then gorge like i said it's like a
little area right behind the vaginal
wall where you might be fighting looking
for the g-spot okay um and you can see
it's still on the front swells still on
the front side okay and it swells and
very eventually that's also has
prosthetic fluid in it and when
stimulated um a woman can ejaculate now
here's the thing about ejaculation it
can feel amazing like an incredible
lease release
but it's not necessarily if you can
squirt and not orgasm you can orgasm and
not squirt
so i think that squirting became really
popular during like with the advent of
porn or with porn being in our available
in our pocket in our pocket all the time
um and see it's time to see some more so
many more women squirting so i just have
gotten so many more questions about it
since then
but it's definitely like a fun thing to
explore you can help your partner do it
using fingers or your penis or a toy and
really it just comes from continued
pressure
to that internally pressure pressure
pressure
feeling of release and then she can
release and learn i think that many
women can learn to score it and just
take some time
because it gives you this
it's a different type of
i i can relate to it because like with
an ejaculation there's a sense of
completion
is that
would you describe it in that way
it's not necessarily completion so what
i was saying for many women they have
one
and they just feel released and it feels
really good but it's not necessarily an
orgasm now some women have it
alongside their orgasm like they have it
within or i mean they have it with an
orgasm and they squirt and it's just
different for all different kinds of
women to say if they would define it as
completion
but they might define it as like uh
just like a really intense release that
could be kind of emotional
physical
everything and once you once you
know that it is a possibility and you
have experienced it it it can be this
thing where
well
we got to go until that happens because
that's the side i think that's kind of
what you're getting at like that's the
sign that
is that this definition
has been done
you know we all get to define what
success looks like in a relationship and
an orgasm that's why i hate to put
labels on it it's like was it success
like how did your partner feel
did she feel good bad did she feel like
it was a pain in the ass or without the
pain of that pain in her bulba did she
feel like it wasn't like a fun thing to
do like that's to me is what successful
sex is or did we talk about it did we
both get our needs met whatever our
needs were that day
was there some aftercare we cuddled
after we talked about things like to me
that's a successful rock
okay well let's talk about missionary uh
not just because we used to be
missionaries um
which is no exaggeration could i enter i
just had one okay
where have you been my whole life yes i
was like
one thing to go back um with squirting
well like the first thing with that was
there's such an interesting because i am
a vulva owner who has scored it in the
past and i think one of the things
that's so interesting about it is
there's a weird mix of
oh that's so amazing and and shame as
well like i totally have been with a
partner before and i have squirted and
then my partner was like oh gosh what is
all of this and it made me feel like
what it was like they were and it was it
was early on in my like sexual
like
[Music]
awakening i suppose so like
still trying to feel comfortable so i
know a lot of other
women have experienced that i'm also one
of the 25 percent
as well who can do can have the vaginal
but that was something that i learned on
like solo trying out things with myself
masturbating like that that was like in
my own sexual awakening separate from a
partner but then yeah having those
discussions with partners now of just
like you're gonna be chill with all this
stuff right like this is a good thing
yeah i'm so glad you brought this up you
just brought up like so many great
points the first thing is that like
yeah a lot of us have been shamed by a
partner that's i once had a partner
who's like i remember like i got my
period or something and he was like oh
god like we gotta change the sheet to
take a shower and like call 911. i'm
like
are you kidding me like it wasn't great
so so then we get shaded like i have to
put blankets down in sheets down and
there is that partner who shames us all
the time like oh it's a mess and yes
i've had guys call in and be like it's a
mess and i don't want it it's fine and
like i think like
throw a towel down throw a beach towel
down like do something there's except
there's throws that are just made for
sex because sex can be messy um i think
if they're not preparing it or maybe
they're a little ocd like that just rock
their world so i'm sorry you got shame
that way but i just again yeah we wanted
to go into partners or like bring it
like messy and hot sex is all those
things and those are the partners that i
choose to be with but yet it's you know
we all have people from the past that
were like that was not a good lesson
that i not a good message that they sent
me because now i feel shame about it but
hopefully we can move on from that
was that i mean were you surprised at
that time or were you like this is your
oh yeah i was super surprised it was the
first time that it had happened for me
so i was also like
because like i didn't really watch porn
so i didn't know necessarily that that
is something that is
what happens and then you know my my
sexual education was
lacking of course but then um yeah i
started talking to my girlfriends
because my girlfriends and i are all
super open with each other and i started
asking them i was like
is this weird he said it was weird and
then my friends were like absolutely not
[ __ ] him like that's amazing that
happened to you i'm so happy for you
and like you can find that with somebody
who's gonna be like really excited but
yeah it was a weird like i had to just
feel comfortable sharing the experience
and feeling comfortable talking to my
friends about it and like
i think that's what i suggest for a lot
of younger
um women who are
starting their like sexual journey is
like talk to your friends like as soon
as i start talking to my friends we have
the best conversations about it like
it's great it's great it's exactly it
well i i mean yeah that that's that's
true for for us too i mean it's like i
was giving you a hard time not telling
about the butt plug but there's a lot of
stuff that we talked about and
encouraged each other and it's like oh i
i discovered this or this works for us
well i just feel like in the conte i
have to tell this story
um
so
again this is probably
16 17 years ago um
when me and you were
emceeing big break
okay so this is like this is when we
were in it to win it on the the
christian um
missions you know side right and so we
were emceeing this conference
uh for campus crusade
down in panama city and the you know
it's basically a bunch of college
students coming together and then they
kind of they go out on the beach and
you know
try to talk to people about jesus
and
so we're up there like we're leading the
thing doing our comedy stuff in front of
all them does that make you horny
and at that conference because you know
the cool thing about it when being on
staff is like oh we get to stay in this
nice hotel and like me and jesse get
this time together right and at that
time
uh i don't think we had it
maybe it was before we had kids or we
left the kid i left lock at home i don't
know but anyway during that at that
conference in that hotel was the first
time that we ever experienced jesse
squirting
and again and i had i even though i was
a good christian boy i had watched
enough porn to know exactly what had
just happened and i was like yes you
know like um
but yes it was just so funny that it
happened in the in the context of this
and we've talked about squirting before
yeah um so yeah this this thing is not
news to me but and then for me you know
it's i i have this reputation of being
uh
like some people might say ocd or ocpd
or like they you know it's it but i'm
you know and i'm a clean freak and i
like things you know certain
i i i take joy in cleaning things and
ordering things and organizing things
but when it comes to sex there was a
decision that i made
that was i don't know when i made it was
a long time ago and i think it was a
result of the conversations that we were
having and it was just like you know
what this is fun this is an adventure
this is a place for play this is a place
for discovery it's not about um
you know as long as you're both on board
and you're communicating there's the the
world is your oyster
and
so
that was that was kind of my approach
and then saying you know what there's
something that i might
my
knee-jerk reaction might be oh this is
this is this could be dirty you could
see this as dirty or you could see this
is gross it's like
well and that was the advice that we
were getting
so the one piece of advice that i got
from somebody who actually
talked to both of us
before we got married who was in our
lives at the time
uh yeah was and again i i think you know
as
as much as we talk about our christian
background the thing i will say is that
we did come from a particular tradition
in which
uh even though there were some very
restrictive views on sex and who sex
could be with it was obviously only
between a man and a woman and only in
the context of marriage that was sort of
the pretense but right
within that con in the confines of that
there was there wasn't a whole lot of
shame it wasn't as shame based as it is
in a lot of tradition so i'll say that
that's why i think that we ended up
having
pretty good sex lives from the beginning
because we got kind of lucky with the
specific people we were talking to but
one of the things that i was told
from somebody who kind of mentored me
was like
everything's okay but just stay away
from the butthole and that was that was
it was just like that was his one piece
of advice and it was not grounded in
anything yeah so i think that that is an
idea and that's just not a christian
idea that's a cultural
yeah idea so we're back to that but in
general
i'm
i'm glad to say that i've reaped the
benefits of
um
checking any sort of uh i don't know
what the word would be like um
just my assistance my resistance or
hesitancy at the bedroom door and saying
you know what this is
this is a place for us to have fun
together
and
so let's be adventurous
um and let's see what we can discover
and that that's led to a whole lot of
fun i think my tendency is is actually
to
um
just find what works and just just go
back to it you know like i'm a creature
of habit like if i find a if
if i find the right answer or if i if i
you know where the gold nuggets are i'm
gonna go back to that same yeah
mine you know so
there's a
i think there's a discipline to saying
okay i'm gonna keep working at this i'm
gonna keep building
skills and experiences
and that
it
there it there's some there's a level of
commitment and
energy involved in
like
continuing to prioritize your sex life
right yeah yeah couples that i mean
exactly like couples
have to continue to build a dialogue
around sex
and talk the more people talk about it
it becomes way more comfortable
and you get to talk about things like
all the time to the point where it
becomes as comfortable as talking about
the weather you look forward to talking
about sex
because you now know that you're on the
same page all the weird stigmas go by
and you're like oh how was that for you
you almost feel like a play-by-play like
last night what'd you think of that new
thing i did with the toy or my finger oh
yeah i love this part didn't love that
part like that's the world that i want
to see couples and people living in
where it just sex is like of course
we're going to talk about how am i going
to know you're not a mind reader
i'm not a mind reader so yeah i want
couples just to continue to enhance and
have these conversations and
it's gonna change everything because the
couples that talk about sex have better
sex well that's
one of the things nothing was more just
to add to that nothing was more amazing
than when i heard the feedback was like
wow that was magical and it felt like a
mouse was running out of a garden hose
what
hey
i guess you had to be there uh i'm glad
i wasn't um
so
that that is one of the things that i'm
really uh that i honestly think has been
a key to maintaining a
you know 21-year marriage now
um
it was is first of all just blessed with
just a natural communication with with
jesse that was like
we've from the very beginning regardless
of the background that we're from we
talked very openly about everything so
the communication has never been an
issue which i'm just thankful for
because i know that's not and that's not
for everybody
right um
and then i kind of see this sort of
sexual adventure for lack of a better
word just a broad term is like that's
one of the ways you kind of pace out
the uh the
the progression of your relationship you
know what i'm saying it's like
even today you've shown me remote
controls and stuff and i guess i could
have told you that those things existed
specifically but we don't have those
things in our house it's just a it's a
wonderful time to be alive right it's a
wonderful time to be alive to know that
like
okay you can kind of pace these things
out i mean
oh we're introducing this new thing into
into our sex lives that we can kind of
enjoy for a while to me that's one of
the ways that it can continues to stay
sort of vibrant and continues to get
more exciting as you go is like
pacing this stuff out introducing new
things because i mean because i'm i'm
the same way and that you're like okay
well which kind of gets back to the
conversation i was going to with the
missionary thing somehow i've garnered
the reputation especially from trevor
um who's one of our
mythical kitcheners that me and jesse
are really into missionary sex he just
really thought that was a funny joke and
then uh
really really went for it and the funny
thing is is that yeah we kind of are
we're into a lot of things but i would
say that that is
you know if you were to see a pie chart
of all the sex that jesse and i have had
the majority of the pie chart would be
in the missionary
position well it gets a bad rep what's
your question uh
[Music]
i i don't know if there's a question
here as much as
why do you think mission okay yeah why
do you think missionary gets a bad rap
michigan gets a bad rap because well
first it's the position that we just
kind of go back to over and over again
so it can get really really boring
and it's kind of our go-to
but there are ways to keep it more
interesting and to spice it up it
doesn't have to be the way that you
understand it to be you know why people
i think just because it's the basic
position but you can't spice it up like
with more eye contact
there's different ways to
uh sit during it you could be sitting up
where your partner comes in like
you could be like sitting on the end of
the bed
where your partner comes in standing
like i actually just did a
podcast on this making missionary hot
and i talked all about this like there's
just all these ways that we just kind of
do it the same way and then there's just
like different leg positions there's
something called the cat position which
is the coital alignment technique
where harder to explain today but
literally it's missionary but your
partner
uh on top is just sort of scooted up a
little bit further so you have more
um stimulation on the pelvic floor area
that can actually lead to more orgasm so
there's just like
it gets a bad wrap because it's all we
know and it's really standard and your
partner can just go in and pound away
like a jackhammer but i like to give
hacks for it well and so but you you see
those alterations is still missionary
because i i agree like
so
if you're facing each other that's
missionary if i would just roughly i
would say yeah if like the two bodies
are facing each other in general but if
all of a sudden your partner
puts her leg straight up in the air and
like an l shape i mean i don't know we
got to come up with more names i think
you know there's different types of
missionaries man
you've got the mormons who are doing
like two years in foreign countries and
stuff right uh you got the people like
us who are going to college campuses you
got people who are going
you know there's lots of missionaries
the jesuits are sending people all over
the place
so i just think we need to update the
terminology like i like to think of the
position when you put your your legs up
that's like a jesuit thing because
they're always kind of like
i just feel like they're on the cutting
edge a lot of times the jesuits
i don't know maybe it's just my lack of
cutting experience with jesuits but
they just seem like they're like smart
and like doing things
so
i call it the listen to the ears
no i meant i meant to say i call it
listen to the feet
no because my the feet are by your ears
yeah
yeah what did it it's like what did the
ear what are the feet saying what are
the feet saying from right here
okay emily this has been very
enlightening i i i you've got so we came
to a gentle landing with a missionary
well i would say uh to use the prostate
analogy uh we would like to
[Music]
milk you for a just a few more facts a
few more tips
that didn't come out great um but this
is a safe space so if you could give us
three sort of parting tips
sex tips sex tips for everybody
that are like okay okay if you could
remember these three things
to take with you that we haven't talked
about okay so i would say
uh foreplay starts after the last orgasm
meaning
um
we
foreplay all day continuing to keep that
spark alive a lot of couples are like we
had sex we did it and then the next time
you come together you're like we don't
feel as connected so send a sexy text in
the middle of the day like talk about
your sex life keep sex top of mind
you'll be making your sex easier can you
dictate that text to me right now
no okay i got it what's that what's the
next hot tip i mean the next one would
be i would say communication is a
lubrication the more we talk about sex
the better sex we're going to have that
would be like my timing tone and tur
stuff
information and the next thing i would
say is
slow everything down go five times
slower than you think sex sometimes
moves way too fast and if we like slowly
kiss our partner we slowly undress each
other we move like we just sort of put
more intentionality and more presence
with our partner i think that we'll find
a lot of us who will be having more
successful sex hmm that's good those
those are good good words you know you
should have like a show or something
where you talk about sex because it just
feels like every time you say something
is very insightful and like based and
like grounded in facts and
evidence-based
you should really think about that i
should you know what thank you that
clitoral hoodie thing you gotta gotta
run with that that is genius i wrote it
down
all right then tr travel pillow is mine
yeah yeah i'm taking that one as long as
you just send us a couple or four send
us four clitoral hoodies when you come
out with that that's all we ask
done
thanks so much emily and rex thank you
for having me
did do you have one in right now just be
honest do i have i know i don't wear the
butt plug to work but if you want me to
start i will no no no not yet i'm gonna
just keep asking myself
thank you emily thank you so much for
having me this is fun
yeah hope you hope you learned a lot
listener
well that was fun
it was it was you know it was it's i
love talking about this stuff i don't
want it to necessarily be
every single episode but it's there's
just something about saying that like
hey you don't have to
feel
shame and embarrassment when you say
things and talk about these things it's
not an easy thing it's not an easier
easy barrier to overcome i love the fact
that
for the second year in a row these
conversations kind of bring it to the
forefront of my mind and say all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna give a lot more
attention to
to sex and think of new things be
exposed to new
principles techniques well you seem to
be so yeah i'm uh i'm i'm actually very
very excited to go home today i will say
you you took issue with me not telling
you about my butt plug experience which
boy i mean
maybe you did not block it maybe i
wasn't ready i think i have told you
about it
uh
secondly what are those people on tumblr
that think me and you have sex with each
other are gonna do about this
like what are they gonna like how do how
do they
i don't think about those people but the
thing i really want to ask you is
do you want me to tell you every time i
do something new
is that what you're asking yeah
okay
yes all right
do you want me to send you my old butt
plugs when i upgrade to new more
technologically advanced ones
no okay
uh do you want me to tell you
uh because i mean i try things new to
you like just because
i mean there's plenty of things i'll try
i need to think about it
[Laughter]
uh i am up for i
i believe you
every day i'm up for more than i was the
day before i believe i put it to you
thank you again to emily morse dr emily
morris you need to listen to her podcast
you know i
i kind of knew of her but i had not
listened to her actually talk about this
stuff uh i you know obviously listened
to some of her podcasts before she came
in here and i was just like man i should
be listening to this on a regular basis
like in just a couple of episodes i felt
like i was like man like this is missing
out i'm a man who has sex with my wife
and i just feel like there's this
treasure trove of information but she
doesn't just have sex with emily she
actually just did a master class
so
oh yeah it's like officially in the
master class subscription center yeah
yeah so you can check out the master
class thing and also lots of resources
and more information about emily at sex
with emily.com when you're taking your
your your toddlers to the playground
bring your jam box and play sex with
emily's podcast i suggest doing it with
headphones on and make sure that it's
going into the headphones and not coming
out of your phone a lot of times you
don't realize that it's coming out of
the phone
it's just you might be a mixed company
so
uh we got another special guest coming
up on the next episode um emily negoski
uh author of the only speak with emily's
when we talk come as you are great book
um dr emily nagoski only dr emily's and
we are going to uh be speaking with her
and then the week after that we're gonna
be
we're gonna we're gonna open it up
to any
questions any any sort of i don't know
exactly what the prompt is we'll figure
that out what do we say we'll put it'll
be on the it'll be online
of course go ahead and leave a voicemail
um let us know what you think about this
episode we love your responses one eight
eight eight earpod one and of course you
can use
ear biscuits so we'll speak at you next
week sex timber continues
it elongates
through the whole month
hey there rhett and link this is kaylee
from michigan
i'm watching your rabbit hole episode
and you're trying to figure out why
young people watch podcasts instead of
listening to podcasts i'm a i'm 25 i
feel like i'm in the young demographic
when i am watching a podcast
it is because if i listen to it
i will start thinking about other things
and then miss
potentially like 20 to 30 minutes
of the podcast and then i have to like
rewind and re-listen to it so i have it
on on my tv like in my home while i go
and do other things like cook dinner or
clean things or like i'm a teacher so
i'll like grade things and then i have
something to look up to
and it kind of like re-centers the
listening
and then i don't miss anything
but i don't just sit and watch it like a
movie
it's just like on in the background so
i'm listening technically like a regular
podcast but my eyes have something to
focus on
don't know if everyone does it this way
but that is why i do it this way
thanks so much bye hi rhett and link
this is yessie from florida i just
finished listening to locke going to a
university in florida and i wish him the
best i'm from miami so university of
miami hurricanes
was in my childhood i graduated from the
university of florida so i'm a florida
gator and i married a man who is an ssu
florida state university seminole fan so
florida baby through and through bye
guys love you hey guys it's leslie the
truck driver going to nevada as usual
every week
thank you for everything you guys do
totally love your biscuits
um never knew that in my 40s and early
50s i would be a groupie for the first
time in my life but i totally am your
groupie love you guys thank you for
everything you do
cannot wait till mythicon guys i don't
care if i get six feet from you 100 feet
from you it'll be awesome to see you and
to see the crew bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]